hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with yamimash over there
say hello hello again I am back yes we
are back with another gmod horror map
this one is death of the doing oh oh I
almost killed myself but it's not a gmod
horror map until we start off the day
with the murder
so anyway we're trapped in a room here I
I think this thing here we hit it no
that's wrong huh
maybe if I throw another rocket at it
hey no I'm back damn back rifice wooden
night I'm such a say hey wait there's a
button on the wall over there all right
yeah behind you right here oh why did we
never see how before I don't know sounds
lights I press eat yeah oh oh no oh god
what okay all right shut up yamimash
there's another button over here what's
that one say well wait hang on something
strange it's oh very smart
first a big red button I did what
happened I just want these metal things
opened up okay all right back to
crowbars only excuse me oh no no no
gingka I'm in the room don't don't do
anything don't don't know anything hey
don't touch anything
do not touch a thing there is a button
up on the but now this out do Kevin
wait hang on a minute ah you bastard
you're dying to kill me how dare you oh
how dare you this burn combination gonna
blow oh hello knocking down head Oh down
there okay there was another door over
here hang on okay
now that we've gotten our daily dose of
murder exceeded all those boxes for you
yeah there was Roger oh wait I can't
break them oh oh oh oh sorry but the box
is a funny one this wall oh this is not
fair hang on there's a
there's a button over there and I
trusted don't present waiting
wait they are lying who's lying the box
is it's pointing is it weight hand
there's an arrow pointing up can I get
through oh I can't no hang on let me
check out the hair uh nothing nothing I
sure hope this little riddle hair was
actually supposed to do it right if
exposed to save me if I'm not mistaken
are you fine
hang on those numbers on the wall yeah I
suppose Press London them because you
pay attention well since I'm already
dead the door opened up over here I
think we failed this room when you let
me die oh god you know I'll take it the
satisfaction of you dying was worth it
okay good make your choices two buttons
here I say left I say right I sure hope
he was wrong what happened nothing
something happened yeah shall we step
back from that flammable gas next you do
so you're worth something and I'll just
keep randomly pressing buttons yeah you
hang on you hear that right click
clacking let me check the other room
over here
Oh door opened oh oh oh you wanna you
wanna step into the fun playroom what do
you want again this is a happy fun room
filled with unicorns and dreams hey I'll
go slowly also scared oh you thought
gear and ice numerous and button over
there hello Joanne Wow no hang on it'll
be fun oh my god Ken he's mine yeah what
the hell I couldn't get in there that's
what she said no that's what he's no
hang on hey buddy how'd she know he said
that's what they said to get oh oh [ __ ]
me first you told me that jump Crouch
work I did did but they wouldn't let us
in I think there was just a ruse to
trick us because we're stupid sacrifice
part two who will live uh what does that
have to mean
well one of us is gonna die have it same
move is about not like we've already
died well you're not in the room so I
don't know
opposite bye I'm right behind you Oh get
in the room uh get in the room good Yami
i'ma get hit
now I stay in there they hit push that
button wait what am i doin
Doughboy now you killed me before is a
little fast push push brilliant I love
this game that's not fair you were
supposed to die
Oh deserves a victory swig my duty you
son of a [ __ ] that was nice books to
kill me boy you not know that people
with beards are immune to death oh just
because you can grow a glorious beard
and I cannot I'm gonna put about your
Rogaine on my face and you'll say oh
okay if it is opened I'm going first cuz
I can't believe this
this game is backwards hub okay this is
safe down there can i but i find there's
nothing darling
oh okay boxes and I can't break oh I
can't break the boxes mine is like the
auntie markiplier business oh this [ __ ]
oh hello
oh brightness hang on there's a door
open the bowl over here alright gonna
I'm going jeez shut up get off my back
you're so oppressive I love you huh
curiosity kills remember um ha ha ha ha
ah
nothing wait hang on Angie that's a lily
sound effect yeah good look
nope nothing okay I some over here my
girl nope uh those reminds those are
mines on the ground ah ah this game it's
a son of a [ __ ] we I have to die so
much in one gmod man oh you never died
so much you can't even complain because
of you I hang on I'm going in did you go
in here I know I'm here hello need a
light pan
huh what are you doing over there
and is how did you get up yeah crouch
jump you losers yeah okay I'm just
follow me into this dark corridor I push
the button I think I saved us but I'm
starting I hope he was gonna die then um
I think I okay go back
I push the button and I think it worked
there you guys get through hit I can't
go through there
ah hey wait a minute we pushed one
button I think that's important okay
let's go in here first hmm about feeling
about you always have a bad feeling how
about you have a good feeling every once
in a while huh there's nothing to feel
good about right now shut up
dinner's served let's eat ooh mmm tasty
it looks like he using a crowbar as a
fork and you're eating it yeah you
weren't gonna join me I'm loving it fine
three on Grover T a dead body a few
times
oh well okay this is the meat locker is
we're all dummies annoyed I'm gonna lock
you in here by Yami oh yes of the
horrible is gonna happen her faith is
not in your hands where is she huh her
faith was that mean come in here y'all
be come here ha oh I don't like to look
at it remember last time hang on I'm
gonna get in the bath with this lady
I've to do that hey how's it going honey
oh you look at the wow oh you Jesus
no there's an iron bar in there oh okay
there doesn't seem to be any I'm gonna
just hand covering run why'd you have to
kill everyone she's still alive she's a
toughy okay all right you one guy in
this room yeah yeah I'll go freedom
yeah I'm Oh but nothing here my Mac okay
I'm not no not on either you'll own
house yes aria-live eyes shut up I've
died so many times it doesn't even hurt
me anymore I can I could end your
suffering if you'd like me to No No
thank you I'm fine okay this is just a
big maze there's nothing here for her
sorry not right now Michelle this is the
other side of the other thing ah new
character model is like firmer than him
very serious ceiling oh he came back ah
what did that even look like uh I shot
my eyes it's just one of those JPEG
images oh I was not all right anyway
moving forward ends I'm going to shut up
I'm going what what else could they
throw at me I pushed a button oh Jesus
get out oh that hurts barely yeah hada a
lot of her bladder hurt apparently for
some strange reason I don't know oh when
I press that button one of the lights
here in the beginning it lit green so we
need to find two more buttons boom or a
so get your butt back here
where'd you go well mi wait I'm just
right here which was I was there
anything over here yes what a chair yes
in the channa nadir outfit for you -
eight seven six
wait a minute - eight seven six remember
that - eight seven six
okay we got to go then point it's really
important Diaby we got to go back we
gotta go boom
that's a literal you oh okay just follow
me geez stop panicking so much your
touchup get a B let's sleep - I don't
like this oh good well I don't know some
the got it this little shakes everything
I think that was it
all right and there's something ah ha ha
wait my clothes ah I just pressed it
where's you late seven six month to $800
you you push that button I really don't
wanna you push the but that's one of the
buttons that we need to activate this to
open the lock push it
oh okay now ah oh I don't
oh yeah well goodbye at night have fun
ah how do I not hope you had a great
time over there Oh Yami are you okay did
that come over here there's something
you need to see I don't know where you
are
I jumped through the hole oh you're in
the room I was in yeah hi come in my
hole ah dirty set those would not dirty
at all shut up okay um hang on let me
man this [ __ ] is just amazed how do we
even end up it well I don't know I'm
done the demons they got me okay this
leads nowhere
okay um hmm
paying for freedom yeah that's asset no
it doesn't it doesn't hurt feels good
actually
ah slice nice on your bony feet who
here's the third button oh I just ah
look
I didn't leave you out there was another
one did you see that no that was another
okay you died before you saw it it was
really cool and all I'm gonna I'm gonna
die too so I can join you in the
afterlife yeah shut down the whole not I
I just spawned give me a second Oh boom
are they all all three buns ring BAM we
are just too good at this game
yeah we are let's do a high-five with
our webcam okay just top ha yeah like
that no did we do it huh yeah okay I
think we did it I think that's good
that sounds perfect when it goes on no
only one who could survive well
certainly not gonna be you so much Oh
whoop Wow Arie my bad
oh yeah no no me first
okay I'm going right you go you go that
way I'll go this way
ah haha wait a minute no I did it wait
oh no you did it
that's buh it was a monster didn't you
would see the monitor did sir you didn't
see the monster huh where is it I don't
know that was I'm oh you're not the
monster what hey hey judge yeah yeah
you're my monster you go Yahoo assets to
this place I don't know it's amazed Oh
figure it out
the monster where's a monster God I'm
lost I'm lost - what the hell this is
this is Jay Pitt ha what neither of us
are gonna survive because we can't get
through the Fergana huh you found it
yeah he's just a big shadow guy where
are you
ah I don't know I've just been going in
the same circle I've been going for
about five minutes
well that's not really good is it no
shut up stop being so patronizing
yeah oh oh I made
oh wait no I have been left to roll you
have escaped thank you for playing oh oh
I have been left to rot this sucks this
game is stupid and I hate it
out here the sky so blue and the noise
son oh it's beautiful
I hate it with a passion this game is
dumb gmod is horrible everyone who likes
it should fall into a hole okay well
with me done I guess we're done I'm so
happy
shove yummy mash I'm not toying away I'm
gonna go lay down to drink some tea just
like yamimash does every day and try to
get unsick no anyway there is another
video that's got to be out on Yami
masters channel probably tomorrow so
firmly maybe I'll try get out tonight
okay alright you got a movie to ghosty
but look out for it it's gonna be a link
in the description click on Yami
master's face eventually that will lead
to his channel so check him out he's
awesome thanks so much yamimash for
stopping by and playing with me again
and thank you max always a lot of fun oh
yes so thank you everybody for watching
and as always we'll see you in the next
video bye bye
get out get out get out get out get out
Flint agent yeah out of here I signed up
chat
Hey